back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
dude you seem like a guy probably that
gets lost at the mall still speaking of
mall you're being a mall America very
easy to do you're in the mall admittin
there's American II there's four
American Eagles at that Mall of America
dude and there's a real to us all bald
eagle there to buy the popcorn there's a
lot of birds yeah I just lived there
crazy crazy bro we are relying you guys
are we are we are oh man boys came back
from lunch at that wet wet kid there huh
yeah you noticed that yeah the waiter
was wet yeah you ever shake somebody's
hand and it's a wet hand you ever shake
the Salamanders hand that wasn't this
kid he looked like one of those wet tree
frogs yeah he had that he kind of really
seemed like a young man who was it makes
sense they see was crank and no one
else's wet he seemed like somebody who
kind of swims to like a surface to
breathe you know he had a very wet like
he tried to shake his hand and would
slip out of your hand so his mom [ __ ]
the tadpole you know every time I try to
shake his hand it just kept like a fin
almost yeah just a wet hand he was very
he seemed like one of the Wet Bandits
from home alone you know like a real wet
bandit like a human seal you're seeing a
seal right when the yeah the water is
real shiny oh I told four are tipped in
$4 extra because he spun that ball on
his nose did you notice that I did see
that nose cool a nice sandwich in a ball
spin but he really has okay we should I
fall ball spin you've been getting lunch
at a massage parlor Samian had me spin
up that salad a mess oh look human
you're gonna go to heaven I bet thanks
dude I think the white guys didn't go to
have him oh yeah they came straight from
the rain forest I'm talking this boy was
wet bro it seemed my keyboard maybe also
he probably worked at Bed Bath and bath
very damp young fella uh he orders to
meet someone and I'm her patting him on
the back and some of us splashed up into
his hair I was like I've never seen
someone so wet in my life I use an extra
off Waterworld [ __ ] gills and just
the moisturizer and everyone else is dry
yeah yet his own little climate going in
also if you notice right up in here his
clavicles they had a little bit of algae
maybe he's a magician or something story
I got a water edition yeah like a water
yeah explain this I want to hear more
about this awkward David Copperfield you
know I'm saying ooh
David aqua field may be wet David Blaine
up in this [ __ ] yeah dude made a nice
sandwich as well and how again it's an
interesting place over there how would
the other young gentleman with the
toupee and acts like it's just all good
okay well we just went from the place we
were at could have been anywhere to now
very specifically the place we were cuz
any the other waiter we could have just
been anywhere it could have been no one
knows where now people know there's also
a young fella in there with a toupee
dude and it's not a good one
you don't think I think it's go out do
it oh sweet toupee well look man a lot
of our forefathers had toupees do dot
they call them big wigs you know that's
where that term came from so did wear
wigs really the term big wigs came from
them when big wigs hmm yeah this guy I
get is it a toupee definitely you think
110% do you how good you were at
guessing at your base can you bring up a
couple toupees and then also some just
regular hair and see if you can make the
difference well here's the best one
Steve Martin toupee started going bald
at a young age and just decide to go to
pay did he I didn't notice that suggest
who pay looks like looks like a shitty
yarmulke that who that guy over there
yeah he's looks at a real fluffy
yarmulke yeah that yarmulke boy that
hair wallet that's what I call it yeah
that here purse well sometimes you see
uh we take a brown clam on his head
[Laughter]
his has a very ocean tide on it that
would he is s time it's glued on like
Ewing you will like you just like hey yo
well damn dude I love it actually I
think it's you pay I can't believe they
don't have more of them really I can't
believe people were just showing their
bald head to the world I feel like it's
so amazing I agree take a little pride
in yourself and get a wig yeah I tell
Callie get a wig all the time like if
it's going dude toupees are fun yeah
that guy you might have that style show
a jheri curl oh you could do a finger
wave the next day or you could do a on
some bangs if you want bang it up yeah
bang it out son yeah I think if you had
a toupee the opportunities are endless
actually they had um we just did a king
of the sting post on the Instagram and
they had a beautiful set of hair
actually on Derek if we can zoom in on
that oh he's basically Beyonce some very
unique hair and also chin if you notice
[ __ ] if chin feels right at home there
it looks right at home he is wearing
glasses now cuz he thought he had a
tumor turns out he just turns out he
just didn't know where he parked his car
turns out he just lost his keys it's not
a tumor
he just lost his keys and they asked him
to wear glass and now so you can find
his keys it's nuts man I the [ __ ] in
rocket to pave and why doesn't you man
what a [ __ ] here's my thing know you're
that strong you're 6-3 it's a half ounce
of hair dude it's not that heavy so hurt
your neck well the old days you know the
original two pagers were very heavy and
people don't know a lot about that you'd
have a four pound you know it had a
leather bass he had a four pounds of
hair and four pounds of leather and hair
not these days man you don't my hair
started going I'd be a different
hairstyle every day I'd be like a black
girl really damn I should come in pink
they said be blue silver black short
with a martini glass and it's sometimes
you'll see like in Louisiana you see a
girl Shep like a you know a martini
glass cocktail half the side Oh she'll
have five shrimp hanging off the edge of
edge of her hair at the
I like it personally I enjoy that dude I
love a snack you know let me pee basic
[ __ ] out here whoa
well I'm just saying stands out here I'm
not saying Cat Cat would you ever wear a
wig um you don't need I thought about it
but that's only because I don't want to
dye my hair again
I do miss colored hair you know what's
weird is when women wear wigs like the
foreplay it's you with a wig on like
you're not that dumb what if they put a
mustache or something on it's you or the
mustache yeah let's bring other chicks
into the room oh I see what this is
about huh
is there a lot of um wigs or prosthetic
hair in Asian culture a lot of
extensions not necessarily wigs and I
think they're now catching on to wigs
private easiest ethnicity to fake a wig
cuz you guys here's just straight and
black like there's not a lot of variety
not a lot of variety or everyone was
really difficult to die is it really
just so goddamn dark and fine yeah my
hair doesn't lift as well I used to have
purple hair it took me a hot minute to
get there damn I bet you a cool purple
hair can I look like a superhero like an
x-men honestly oh I could say that oh
yeah like an ex-wife on stores like that
triple eggs yeah [ __ ] Lisa Kraft baby
hell yeah um Rayder knock knock who's
there an advertisement look part of a of
adulthood I think is doing things you do
not want to do doing your laundry yes
sneezing getting gas oh good guess
finishing off a bag of peppermint by
yourself at night a footlong burrito oh
um you know I'm saying you also you
never know when you're gonna go be an
adult yeah get some life insurance yeah
look if you're not listening to this
right now it might already be too late
man you might be deceased so what we're
saying we're not talking to you then but
right now what if one of your friends is
listening to this and you could have
handled things better for yourself and
for them by having a life insurance
policy you talk about policy
genius it's the easiest way to shop for
life insurance online in just two
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers to find your best price yep it
makes life insurance easy they can help
you find the right home insurance life
insurance auto insurance and disability
insurance you think you're gonna be
disabled
bet on yourself all insurance man so if
you need life insurance but you just
don't want to deal with all the the
legwork and the hassle head to policy
genius.com the easy way to compare all
the top insurers find the best values
for you policy genius delegate what you
hate especially if you hate getting life
insurance trying to keep lights on dude
I got to apologize to you Brendan I know
you know I sent you something for your
birthday when was your birthday March
18th yep it's still haven't received it
you haven't and you also you messed up
because you didn't use shipstation no I
did not you did not use it that's why we
use shipstation it's the fastest easiest
most affordable way to manage and ship
your work orders dude yeah I gave it to
this dude Vernon and he was supposed to
bring it over there dude you can't do
that you gotta give a shipstation about
what I sell it was very nice no matter
what you're selling it on my what your
shipping Amazon XE your own website once
in your friend birthday gifts
shipstation brings you all your orders
in one simple interface making them
really easy to manage for any device
even your cell phone oh yeah yeah if you
are if you're running a small business
especially shipstation helps you get
orders out quickly save money on
shipping costs and keep your customers
happy it works with all the major
carriers including USPS FedEx UPS even
Amazon Fulfillment all of them no wonder
shipstation the number one choice for
online sellers just ship more and less
time with the best rates available and
right now our listeners can try ship
station free for 60 days when you use
promo code cats K ATS yup which is how
Brendan naturally spells it there's
absolutely no I'm just joking bro you're
good well but I sometimes I joke too
much there's absolutely no risk you can
start your free trial without even
entering your credit card information
just go to shipstation dot-com click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in tax ka TS
yep that's shipstation comm then enter
promo code ka TS support the podcast
let's do it huh the cat Raider hey boys
we'll get into the system debate club
click ad would you ever do braids you
trying to make you corner raised before
cornrows I don't like the Kawhi Leonard
Allen Iverson look man told you watch it
too much bro I don't need all that in my
life listen doing drive-bys yeah I feel
you because you have an old school
you're kind of that Frederick Douglass
kind of freelance start like that
Frederick guarding that liberation
station I like that
deliberate have you ever dyed your hair
now mm-hmm ooh black guys dying stuff
really only blonde yeah yeah and you
also have to be a receiver for that you
got to be on the Cleveland Browns oh
yeah they're really good at catching
balls
yeah they don't let you do it unless
yeah you gotta be obj or whatever ok yn
dude I dare the team the dance moves
dude was he gonna Dancing with the Stars
sure he will be no that was a cruise but
I feel yeah right let's go
Victor Cruz ejido oh yeah oh sauce all
of you but also what um deck I was all
wet bro don't waiter so what I can't get
over it so wet there was a little
treasure box like open fake treasure box
down by his feet I was like this guy's
damn do you know like one of the guys
off of Pirates of the Caribbean have
come out of the sea he look like one of
their men he locate the Carribean dude
he's wet you said puka shells long
that's not just wet bro he was dripping
he kept pulling she's shaking the water
out of his eyes weird he had little
birds are sipping off of him
oh yeah yeah he was a real he seemed
like a real kind of you know kind of
like a wet guy you know yeah I feel it's
such an interesting Bunch over there
between him and the toupee dude man it's
always a fun time in there oh yeah hmm
and then you go in your cuff and you got
wonder if they have beef in there
I wonder if hair and damp have straight
beef bro Oh
what they do you better put that [ __ ] on
the grill and kill it dude there's what
I'm saying boy hey bro usually people
that do meat shoot it before they put on
them not really if there's beef you
better squash it up and grill about high
school that in the restaurant right
you're wet you're gay oh my god news is
coming to Netflix wedding gay wedding
okay well we had this these two girls in
our town growing up people call them
lerton and dermnet was her name lerton
and erm because one of them had he gets
to kind of her gums and they call her
mr. ed but if you spell it backwards his
derm and the other one that kind of big
nostrils like me and they if you spell
nostril backwards its alert some so it
was Larson and Dermot's everybody called
him what a great t-shirt name kind of a
cute pair really were they cuties yeah
pretty sexy man I feel like if we
generally sexy you know I feel like if
the toupee and the wet got together it'd
be a there'd be a cute pair oh yeah
anything could happen over there but Rob
was soft on your boy and get busy oh
yeah it's a really unique it goes its
own little climate going on yeah she's
in the front is in the back cumulus in
the front all right let's get into this
okay first we got Jack steel this is
Jack steel great name a racking a big
brown we got to Bay Club for you today
water slides or coasters of rollers me
myself big roller coaster guy I like
them the slides boy we'd be slipping and
sliding now here
boys on a dating game buzz buzz my high
friends
roller coasters are waterslides which
one is it
I'm not a big water slide fan to be
honest with ya the little traumatize is
a young man on a water slide but the
water slide also it's such a hassle at
those water parks you gotta have the
aqua socks on those things suck on the
Sun all goddamn day you eating funnel
cakes and sugar you can actually know
you're on the lazy river
it's a nightmare what are we talking
about we're talking about water slides
or roller coasters bro and one time I
was at a water park right and it was but
when they first came out you know when
they had like tidal wave and he could
surf it well I decided to get on that
yeah and I got on there and the thing
shot me out and ripped my pants off they
did my shorts and then ty parks on my
dick piece oh yeah my dad tried chasing
me so maybe I bet it took a while to see
it to know that waders swam up with a
tray of it he works at a waiter park
I've been no scuba gear required um what
is up with these guys are they stoned it
seems like they're a little drug boys a
little drugged up debate clubs lettuce
let me see water slides dude water
slides
ah good way to catch herpes here was a
crazy thing I remember growing up they
had a waterslide at this place land Oh
Pines campground and somebody would do
diarrhea on the slide huh and then
here's what they would do here's the
heroes of the move they would shut the
pool down for five minutes at the bottom
everybody get out then they would just
have us go again I didn't like that
cleaned everything up yeah and they had
turtles that are they had a big pond
right next like I just a natural pond
like just a little like a you know like
a very very little bitty lake you know
and they had some redneck turtles in
there huh they're the ones with the red
I'm not saying derogatory term but
they're Turtles with right on their
necks
oh yeah they had Turtles yeah they'd
have a turtle with a damn mullet in
there you know and uh
show oh man small hands in the back you
know every now and then somebody get a
turtle and take it down the slide with
them and leave it in the pool at the
bottom of the slot was an actual pool
when people would get pissed in there
and Truths don't do well in chlorine it
was fun oh man it was exciting and uh
what was the name of the place Lando
Pines and then you get you up one of
them barks root beers the red root beer
and your whole mouth will get stained
red and your whole face even when you
were a kid yeah and then you would just
want you'd be freezing cold after you
got out of the waterslide you know and
this drinking that barks and just get
your lips all red and they're just
wander off into the woods that's a good
brother metafiles bats living though
brother
chucking and diving them pedophiles but
that's living I didn't have the
pedophiles but that's living but you
send a cold kid back there with [ __ ]
almost lipstick on his mouth through
from that barks red soda bro did you
point in the kids trying to warm up oh
yeah files trying get off crime in the
front but yeah these guys I think you
got to go roller coasters man I don't
like having to put on the you know the
the the the wet clothes and do all it at
such a hassling at the wet sauce yeah
the spongy's the other thing is roller
coasters once I spent with to Six Flags
yeah they need to chill out on that [ __ ]
I don't need to be on a goddamn stealth
jet front row with barely any protection
yes my [ __ ] face it's turned into
seven fights you didn't say in Iran I
think is the seventh flag because that
shit's getting heated over there it's
too much one of them it's like you to
shoot your buddy with a [ __ ] grenade
launcher it's like that's way do you
want to just jumping on a plane hoping
someone catches you yeah let's go back
to Six Flags dude you know dude there'll
be more peaceful it's intense
III I'll be honest I went there a year
ago I had to I told I was scared of one
I told my girl not happening yeah cuz
why I went I don't feel good but really
I was scared and some of the rides are
getting real wimpy too like the Big Bang
Theory ride it's just like you and your
friends just like sit around a coffee
table and kind of complain for a little
bit this isn't really this is in fun Six
Flags is the [ __ ] though but they need
your chill out man they take it down a
notch well they used to have better rise
to they used to have leprosy member that
thing
get on there and you get off with a
disease or something yeah you see up the
CT wagon we're just bumping around yeah
man I missed some of the overrides but
I'm gonna go roller coasters all day who
keeps you dry if you get especially if
you got a kid and they got a diaper on
and stuff and you got to take them off
for the water park in at a place and
everybody's wet and everything [ __ ]
their pants and stuff yeah yeah roller
coasters all day yeah all about 51% went
roller coasters as well and that was a
close battle though
psychos oh I was so tight I wonder I
thought that's all landslide for
rollercoaster waterpark that's it's
exhausted yeah what a river get the [ __ ]
out of my face man what about daughter
parks new it's some 50-year old guy
bringing their daughter out some 24 year
old dime piece of trailer park her
trailer you delinquent up next we got
Michelle root izinski oh yes yeah for
sure shorten your last name I wanna say
I'm a huge fan of the show you're both
so [ __ ] hilarious I appreciate you
both so much
watch the youth you you're so charming
so things are done such a good heart and
I appreciate everything you do thank you
so much he's mean it's [ __ ]
so to make up for your well base you can
honestly only choose one it was saying
aren't you talking about that fake [ __ ]
did you guys well let's see him once
again you can only choose one so if you
could would you rather be a gang gang
buzz buzz buzz buzz lightyear huh damn
buzz it up buzz be a long time in my
pants bro oh yeah welcome to the lava
section a water park of my pants now
girl what's up wants a couple nuts full
of love ah you got me Six Flags in my
pants ah tits are asked here's the thing
people this the yeah tell me the thing
here's this gonna be bro it's gonna be
unhelpful no it's not unhelpful here's
the thing from ya what is the rate for
this we've been waiting mm-hmm you don't
have to choose this day and age there's
girls with front and back they're called
Latinas or black girls only white girls
like assert its picking ethnic girl
they're both yeah I'm sayin but
sometimes if you get a go with both they
get real there's a lot more the
potential for violence is stronger I
like being on my toes do you and hell
yeah I got head movement the other thing
is there's nothing worse than a girl
with a flat ass yeah take a fat ass all
day with some itty-bitty mosquito
titties yeah but if you got those big
hitters in the front you got that flat
ass in the back
that ain't it daddy that ain't it dude
we had a girl when I was young bro B is
12 huh bro I feel bad for him she
probably weighed 77 and maybe 78 pounds
somewhere in there of tits bro 36 pounds
of tits sounds like a movie for TP 20
but it's her brother her little brother
used to get in front of him put both
tits on his shoulders don't you let him
do like Deb's and like squat with it
notice like hold him brother
yeah but yeah man and she had a very
straight parallel you know just straight
figure yeah that's the bummer the we had
a girls seem similar was almost like
godlike sometime when she was gestating
or whatever whenever she was being made
in the womb that a lot of her ass got
lonely and went to beat it yeah we got
that flat a syndrome yeah I mean look I
don't know if that's it the thing is we
had a girl in 7th grade name was
Danielle and she had the biggest tits in
the world only like the darker boys
don't only like the dark skin yeah I was
more of her homey do I that I done boner
turn science oh yeah bro Danny oh let's
take this big tip oh yeah I was out in
the back mr. McGregor's only growing yam
did you feel me [ __ ] welcome to yam
gana Stan yeah I'm bill baby mama's
sweet pitar
I like more I think like you're more
well-rounded or you like though you like
the overbearing watermelons in the front
I like us some ass I think you know I
like some day I like a you know kind of
I don't mind a thick I asked a little
bit of desert fat on it you know I don't
like some of you get that loose loose
fat it can be kind of erroneous but if
you get some of the Kardashians have
that desert fat and you get some of that
desert fat it's kind of yes it's kind of
like it's a like there's meat in there
somewhere
I feel I like that WorldStarHipHop oh
god that's a [ __ ] involved with all that
oh my god you can get guns on there
they'll make it rain with some guns but
whatever dude mix it up deal
yeah I guess so man anyway this tip
magnet trying to get to you oh yeah I
think surely you got them tits Congrats
yeah and congrats to you see me it's on
the real ones man they're hard to find
these days oh wow oh and the crazy so
you see some of these plastic ones just
like somebody ordered a bounce house for
the kids you know you know I'm not mad
at one lady she had on a necklace it
couldn't even set on her chest that it
was so bouncy you know I'm not mad at it
was yeah but sometimes you see somebody
they installed them wrong and sold them
way up here by their clavicles you know
you're like what I don't what else
yeah it just seemed like two big-ass
[ __ ] tonsils bro - you know two
tumors on her neck no not tumors like
tonsils dude anyways I like hurt freak
they're her real titties
they're cool man yeah I think you're
cool where you see it I think Russian la
man look if the world's end and I'm
gonna be right up next to you about him
tits so good to see you thank you be
well in Dallas y'all an ass man you
asked for tips look you don't have to
pick her question was a sort it's to our
19 you'll have to pick get you an ethnic
girl go I say both ass and tits
so and if you girl doesn't have tits you
could also just spin them around and
draw nipples on their ass or put a
little her she put them Tollhouse
morsels on our ass if you want overnight
or she's thick enough you make her
[ __ ] tricep a titty you know I'm
saying
what do you else you got do we got a
little flower boys let's plant some Lots
first I hope I'm saying his name right
Johnny flea mono mono mono vamanos
boom my way mono with god damn fuego
mamacita oh that's her on the left there
mm-hmm
she looks like an extra from that thrift
shop song with Macklemore
what what what she looks like
Cruella de Vil a little bit yes you say
she look like she got about 30
Dalmatians brah she's a she's a
traveling are in an avid thrift shopper
and knew it
she's a beautiful aunty of two teenage
daughters of this lady right in the blah
I am when the one on the far right we're
talking about the mamacita the thrift
yes she's the aunt in the one who's
sitting in is the blonde woman that's
her sister that thrift store vixen it's
rare you get a thrift store victim in
this [ __ ] beautiful and this is flop my
aunt oh yeah this is good wheels finest
and is that real fur do we know if
that's fake what is that alpaca
mogadishu what is it
it's about as real as that waiters to
pay nothing he's fake [ __ ] and is that
crown real achieve of royal descent
that's a good question damn lips are
real though
Brendan respect is a woman but there's a
lot of fakeness going around these days
I'm proud of her what else can you say
about this girl Derek uh I like your
jacket Game of Thrones vibe going like
the mother of bad jackets or something
you know
yeah you ever been in a thrift store oh
yeah a little my dad used to bring me my
brother in there every Saturday and say
you can pick one thing I should get one
ski sometimes oh wow
pretty so just a random baseball card I
used to get a vase or like a plate said
I might get a high-heeled yeah why not
um yeah she seemed like kind of Italian
she's got that faint is this ripped my
drip thought my slump Mont yeah look I'd
be here a little nephew you know I would
definitely come out of her sister's
vagina if she needed me to and I think
she's that code is pretty sexy sexy
goodwill vibe I'd buy a youth jacket or
some [ __ ] if she wanted yeah you got to
get that coat pressure wash though I you
know if you get any furs and that's rule
number one
if you get any furs out of our 99-cent
shop or half or a Salvation shop you got
a pressure wash that [ __ ] you got still
yeah you know one does and you don't put
it in a washing machine you need to
really hit that thing right there where
the follicles and the lat water you have
no idea what's been in there
yeah and you could even boil that [ __ ]
obviously and then drink a little bit
out of the pot and just taste if you
taste something [ __ ] foreign or a
little bit of paint because most people
aren't giving up their mink coat to the
goodwill and this has some bad juice on
it yeah or some murder happening that's
what I'm saying that mafia murder gives
those up yeah so this could be I might
be in New Jersey
goodwill yes you got that Jon Snow
though she got that Janice snow cone
look and I'm not matter she yes you got
some nice live days looks like nice she
has a nice arm you can't see that other
arm
she's a goodwill model bro yeah they
call it goodwill out here orgy caught
the Ark out in LA where anyone know what
the Ark is in Aurora we caught the ark
the ark it's called the ark it's another
discount place
oh no out here it's Buffalo Exchange and
goodwill goodwill Salvation Army that's
it I think and I think the Salvation
Army we should let them fight whoever
you know what I'm saying bro release the
hounds I want to say let's unprotect the
border some only bro throughout throwing
old paintings at people they go [ __ ]
win in a heartbeat
throw an old tennis racket the people
well you want the serenity prayer you go
to ding uh you go to the Salvation Army
all right let's keep it cruising huh
yeah up next we got uncle Eddie this is
Uncle Eddie oh oh
gang bro Eddie's on some sort of ride
there and how it looks like Eddie is on
is that Magic Mountain or Space Mountain
yeah uh grow it looks like uncle Eddie's
on that muffin dust you feel me and he's
throwing up the the Satan devil horns
there on a kids ride and he's also in a
tank on Space Mountain so there's a lot
of questions going on oh he'll Huff a
gram right out of a [ __ ] you know out
of a fellow's but this yeah in the front
key it's in the back space bound that's
aggressive outfit for Disneyland bro
yeah he I don't think I don't like
wearing shorts around children
antimatter dude that's me specially at
Disneyland what are you doing Garrick
what do you think about this white guy
that's obviously doing something well
he's a teacher there's no little
backstory about him who knows all the
Shakespeare mmm this guy
teacher I think he confuse Shakespeare
with fast and furious movies Shakespeare
know he teaches dodgeball he's this this
is a PE teacher if I've ever seen one
well now that I look at him a little bit
more he definitely seemed like he could
have us you know he might be a very
smart guy Bernie you can't just tell
about looking at him if he's smart
enough people that know Shakespeare
don't throw up Satan's horns and wear
tanks to Disneyland brah and there's
nothing wrong with being a PE teacher my
favorite teacher name was mr. bubbles
really and he's a great PE teacher gave
me a San Jose Sharks hat when I was a
kid before they came out shout-out to
dr. bubbles we used to have a lesbian
lady and she wanted to make all the
girls tits hard that's what she said it
was tits hard that's what she really
yeah hey what is it be gym teacher go
let's move ladies ever because ladies
don't want to move sometimes didn't make
sense everyone let's pick it up ladies
we had a guy named coach Hill any be
like wait what are you doing there
numbnuts at City College
you jackass Oh coach calls are we other
other coach call slap dicks yeah let's
get moving slap dicks does that even
mean pick it up ladies that's that's
like every dad when the weather when it
starts raining they go but we need it
but we need that says that every time
you know me your damn numbnuts our let's
get moving ladies that name shout-out to
the speed teacher though you ain't
fooling nobody may seem like a decent
guy yeah I like them to pay the bills
look I gotta tell you that sometimes you
get a suit and it ain't what it's
supposed to be dude I ordered a nice
suit the other day they sent me a
swimsuit sometimes you don't know it's a
Wild West of suits may look like you're
you're rocking your dad's suit you look
like amateur not anymore though
not anymore dude getting into Chino bro
yeah doing the chena the world's most
exciting made-to-measure men's worse
company period Oh anything's better I
ended up at a wedding in a two-piece
dude so embarrassing not what I was
expecting but here's how it works do so
you don't look like a [ __ ] yep indogene
oh I already know it's the world's most
famous made-to-order suit site looking
to get married business whatever you got
going on visit a stylist at the showroom
over 40 showrooms in North America and
have them take your measurements
personally or measure at home yourself
and shop online at endo Chino calm I
choose your fabric choose your design
submit your measurements and boom yes
you're ready you're ready suits for all
occasions if you want to be in the Mafia
if you want to you know stand outside of
a bank and look like you're doing
something won't look like a soprano yeah
if you want to look like uh like a
butler
Santiago you know whatever you want to
do like a Backstreet Boy you want to go
to chill a you know relax while your
suit gets professionally tailored and
mailed to you in a couple of weeks
Malcolm 50% off the regular price this
week the king of the sting listeners and
viewers can get any premium industry no
suit for just three hundred sixty nine
dollars at Indo chino calm winter promo
code k 80s
check out that's 50% off that's half off
yes free shipping bra into Chino dock
tom promo code cats for any premium suit
for just 300 $69 and free shipping
that's right
look nice feel nice Indo Chino get that
suit
once you go custom you know what they
say you never go back
that's what some say ah someone's got to
pay for Brendan's coffee habit man
something stinks in here and it ain't me
it ain't me there cuz I'll tell you what
it might be you know it might be us cuz
we're not using our set bird bro yes you
ever smell something amazing and go up
to me like hey bro ya know real nice it
was get out of my face yeah and I wasn't
walking he goes hey bro set burn good go
on what damn thanks dude oh thank you
bro but I don't have a ton of money to
spay to smell like you smell like a
million bucks because Brahma I can't
tell you again scent bird yeah Oh yo
thanks dude thanks a lot simpered is a
luxury fragrance subscription service
mix up your cologne or perfume routines
whatever you want they got over four and
fifty designer brands for me to choose
from each month
I've heard of gucci tom ford kenneth
cole Burberry prada birds that's right
baby
choose the cologne you want to try in
the center for 30-day supplies you want
to smell good you want to feel good you
want your city your skin smelling good
get that she sent bird baby cry baby
baby you guys get 50% off your first
month today that's only seven dollars
and fifty cents for your first fragrance
that's right go to cent bird not calm
/ke 80s use my code k 80s for 50% off
your first month
again that's SCE in TBI rd calm /k 80s
to try your first cologne or perfume for
just seven dollars and fifty cents sign
on smell amazing knock knock who's there
Pacey old Brendan up next how about a
little relationship advice
favorite part really like we're really
we need some new segments - we got to
think of you and I need to get together
next week and think some new segments
along with these yeah I like rip my ride
you do [ __ ] all right
I like rape my driver people send
pictures of their over driver or whoa
hold on hold on we got a question what
you say there I was thinking maybe loss
I think said rape my driver
oh no he said I would never say that no
I'm saying like okay well then say it
more your live driver and you send a
little video and tell us what kind of
music that are listening to how far was
the drive shot of Kathy's oh you saw
yeah that could be break my pup set in
your animals no cheering rate my pop
what the LA again we come up with more
catchy terms it's just off the dome
peace bro yeah yeah yeah that's how I'm
afraid of dude you like to rate my uber
driver no I hate my animal what about
rip my body bro no one thinks I'm saying
rape unless you're a psychopath everyone
thinks you're saying rape dude no one in
there dude t that word the letter T has
T in it too right yeah you're thinking
rape bro you know I don't take a shirt
on that's why uh beginnig you're saying
it I don't think things that people
aren't saying like if you're singing a
song to me I don't think like oh man you
know wish I could find a job right now
you know are these new things that think
that people are talking about well I'm
just saying it could be cool people send
pictures of their boss their animals
their cars their uber drivers lyft
drivers I think it can be fun yeah can
you come up with any ideas yes I can you
know once you get back - since seven
weeks yeah all right first we got some
relationship advice for Cory beam from
Westminster Maryland see being out of
West many old court B oh yeah Roger copy
yo what's up Brandon showers come back
out on the crotch view seeing the little
lumpy bumpy at the bottom of the tree
yeah no nation I think advised my dog
was a really really big world he's done
relationship advice
Danny 38 year old woman I'm 26
she's got two little ones a nine year
old son your own daughter
we've been on and off about two years
and things are going great I love her to
death and I want to be with her forever
but you fight no you do sometimes about
our age if she feels insecure and
because the guy should be with someone
younger and my age but I don't want that
but I want to be with her so I just need
help more now I show her that and how I
can just let her know I love her I don't
want to be with her
thanks guys ganking buzz buzz crotch
bulge out CB huh
buzz buzz - you did game and I've been
on a CB radio before and that crotch
bulge that's the closest thing I've ever
been to since then man they said number
two that ham radio you mean like record
breaker
44 and it's somebody come over to house
and try to molest you some trucker oh no
I don't know we had a guy uh me and this
dude Michael and he was all slicked up
in a jowls his mouth was real damp just
like that waiter wet you know what yeah
he had that freaking yeah
sticky lips it's living just had a damn
watering hole right in the middle of his
face you know and uh some guy came off
we met him on the ham radio CB and he
came over and um dude we're sitting in
his truck bro in this guy's truck and he
was putting I remember he was seeing how
many tootsie rolls minis the minis we
could fit in our mouth right and
Michaels uh some guy was making love to
Michael's mom who was you know she was a
substitute teacher but he cannot beat
the guys ass dude yeah cuz the guy was
gonna take us to like it the guy was
telling he's gonna take us to Florida
and stuff this guy was gonna probably
murder us or whatever hell yeah that
boyfriend's awesome yeah although he's
banging your friend's mom whatever
substitute teacher pie not a lot of
money in the bank but sounds like he's a
good dude
hey guys he was gonna start with tootsie
rolls didn't end up with his dick yeah
sounds like he saved you guys well I'm
grateful Michael it could fit almost 14
many's in his mouth
you fit I would probably stopped at
about 6 or 7 I got nervous because of my
airway I bet simplify Michael was just
he didn't care about his Airways didn't
care if he knew my lord deep though he
didn't care if he met the Lord that
afternoon I don't think what
yeah dude and thankfully it took so long
because then that guy came out and beat
that dudes up to the suit teacher what a
hero and Clint was that guy's name
shutter click the slit but with like a n
in it with the guys question I'll just
age different yeah he's he's younger
than he's 26 his girl's 38 with two kids
dude it sounds like he is that that
young energy he's trying to do all this
[ __ ] he's trying to jump on YouTube he's
Netflix and chill and and go to [ __ ]
Six Flags and do all this and listen to
little nas acts you're too much you got
the young energy take her to a park read
a book go to Barnes & Noble maybe some
bingo whites watch Philadelphia and talk
to I'm saying no I don't man I watched a
notebook and then discuss it over tea
what are you saying did you hear his
statement yes he loved a woman well she
believes that maybe he's too young for
her and he should find somebody his own
age that's what I'm saying so old and up
bro no you don't artists start hanging
out in the Sun so your face looks older
oh yeah maybe dye your hair why again
yeah dye your hair white dude complain
talkers stand in the yard and go like
this all the time stare out of the front
of her yard and make sure no one's
stepping on if they do you [ __ ] yell
at him yeah in a lawn chair yeah get
some graham cracker op a couple n bombs
during dessert got a jabra you gotta
give out coins during Halloween yeah
oh dude here's the thing she might be
trying to lead you away dude if she's
saying you got to go find somebody
younger that's what I'm think that means
she has that old long dick game waiting
for why she's a longer Silver Fox
waiting for and maybe I like it but this
guy sounds kind of a dull it doesn't
sound like he needs to be babysat it
sounds like he's ready to go he's fired
up yeah I know yeah he seems super
mature he senses a video from his nuts
[Laughter]
[ __ ] him what do you think Garrett uh I
think I'm agree with with what you feel
I think she's looking for a George
Clooney brochure no offense but she just
she's not into it man yeah too much
she's not into it she's challenges whoo
why would you tell her younger don't
bang young girls yeah go bang young
girls dude should I be a freak though
those older girls are free well yeah but
that isn't we gonna do with this Brendon
underdog you son on the fat side he
might be Dana reacts well she might want
him to [ __ ] younger chicks and tell her
about it she does that over a matinee
movie you know I'm saying no I don't
know what you're so gonna hook up with
old [ __ ] Dean oh yeah with her killer
yeah we dated on the banging on the door
her kids were banging on the mom she's
like we all watch TV for five minutes
yeah D over here's just balls deep in my
mom oh I got dark how old were you look
17 how old was she like 29 well yeah but
that was at the time that was like do
you feel any remorse about an hour no no
I think the daughter was gonna be fine
because she went she did open the door
she was like mom I just wanted some
juice like she was so calm about it like
this happens all the time I see this
daughter's gonna be fine where'd you
meet this older lady yet uh my dad used
to work there like though you know he
drops off like chips and snacks for gas
stations in the morning like no such
people he told me that there was this
hot girl what we're doing and so I was
like you know my dad always thought
about this guy so I'll pull it in she
was in there started holler at her and
then a [ __ ] I thought it my dad drops
the [ __ ] off she's like oh I like that
guy and that was it man yeah I know
do you keep in touch with the kids or
what the woman no no it was it was after
that night we never spoke again just
still many times the one one time old
lady hit her yeah how and how long ago
was that if we fund the kids right now
what age you need the kids would be are
we talking I'm 29 we're talking 12 years
man and hell where the kids at that
point they were all like eight nine just
kiss oh we could call one of the kids
you like hey do you remember listening
like Oh
there was a young Morgan Freeman with us
Morgan Freeman [ __ ] our mom nope dude
a buddy of mine said that Sinbad hooked
up with his mom when he was a kid and
letting him narrow
left a pair of orange pants at his house
true story I'm here in Gary Indiana
I can send bad dude hopping loads
leaving orange pants in good huh yeah
soon right yeah brother let's get out of
this we got what are we even doing even
her advice are that we're given the the
dick camera dude advice on his older
girl it to me it sound like maybe she
don't really want to be in it bro but
she looking for a George Clooney in your
yeah your little nas ex you're a Bobby
clowny you know yeah but not in a bad
way you're this young man and looked at
things on a ripened fast brother she's
leaving her a dad bro well she's I mean
maybe the guy can provide he looks like
he could work at Wells Fargo or
somebody's probably an entry-level
position so I don't know man
I would ask somebody probably he [ __ ]
knows Brenda you have me too I last
sewing a little more into the game as
you're dealing with some heavy
repercussions here Oh kids 401 K yeah
yeah what are you gonna do do when the
kid starts doing menstruation or
whatever and you got to have a chat with
them and you you don't know [ __ ] yeah
you don't know [ __ ] do you still play
and all you know call a duty or whatever
you can play a fortnight when the kids
run do the homework just those days
goodbye bro you ain't ready you ready
she smells it what else all right up
next a little advice for Mark banks from
Iowa mark the spark baby blaze it up
Gang Gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz
gobble-gobble a ship advice
I've been married for
25 years oh you're [ __ ] I'm great help
me get through anxiety I'm still dealing
with some [ __ ] so I been smoking some
weed and I got caught before doing that
and she wasn't happy about it but
clearly in a shed I thought it helps I
started again and I haven't told her yet
she told me last time that I should tell
her before I try to do anything like
this and you agree to that so question
is should I tell her it seems to help
with anxiety or should I just keep on
keepin on
Oh PS Brendan Schaub you're the coolest
[ __ ] on this planet right now
love you man
whoa obviously you your dad dude you
gotta keep him better contact with your
parents man because are you a bad dude
you [ __ ] tits McGee let's mark the
spark bro and that he loved that dude
that dudes blazing high blazing blazing
he's so high he's hitting on you from
his head behind his house while his wife
is a hottie shed hot [ __ ] right there
dude I love your shadow play the very
end again where he talked three I want
to see what he says I'm not going bad on
him Oh PS Brendan Schaub you're the
coolest [ __ ] on this planet
right now
love you man pretty cool man what a nice
it is a nice guy man
smoking the weed here's the thing if it
helped you especially in 2019 right I do
direct barely got that mad who gets mad
that someone smoking weed especially
have an anxiety sure girls not down with
it man then she's not she's not the one
now I don't know if you're getting high
know what this is and now he's finding
out 25 years later bro
you'd still make mistakes I would
definitely tell her I would 100% tell
her and she's not cool with it she ain't
the 125 years bro oh my god this guy
thought you were cool to divorce what
are you saying them what do you think
they're just gonna live down my street
from each other while he smokes weed yes
some of it and if he makes you better
who's gonna hate on so it makes you a
better person
well that's a good point I think but I
think he's told the wife that he would
let her know if he was gonna smoke it
and he didn't so for some reason he
likes keeping it a secret I think it's
like it's like the one thing he can do
that's like oh that his wife doesn't
know about so he must find some joy in
that yeah it's kind of sneaky yeah he
likes to have something of his own which
i think is okay I mean by not hurting
anybody all right you're not hurting
anybody not her you just said the
jacking off the pornos in this shed and
getting high right I'd keep getting high
man yeah we do and if she says you know
she catches you then fess up to it and
say look there you know and then just
tell her the truth whatever the reason
is why you wanted to keep getting high I
wanted to keep getting high because I
liked doing something that you don't
know about you know I like getting high
makes my anxiety better dude I'll tell
you about this if you're getting high
and you got a wife a little bit of weed
to make your wife feel like a brand-new
woman you know take the sex to a
different place yeah she's complaining
about weed to get her high and then eat
her ass like groceries you know I'm
saying 25 years mix it up bro give it up
give it up give what up dude life advice
don't do it concisely ha oh my god let's
go to cat and get a woman's perspective
I can't even live right here 25 years
bro
keep smoking that hitter you just give
the guy 90 different pieces of advice
man I'm hoping something sticks
and I hope he connects to one he's like
you know I'm gonna get her hi I need her
ass I'm hoping that one sticks now yeah
you blow a little weed smoke in the
bedroom or something maybe booty all
right but you could take her on that
tour but you know just you need to be a
liaison there with her you need to like
you know get her high and leave her in
the other room for a half-hour you know
and sneak around the house and ring a
bell dude no no don't scare don't don't
don't get her high and play [ __ ] the
conjuring you know I'm saying I'll tell
you this after cats a suggestion cat
what do you think well why doesn't she
like like him smoking weed if it helps
with anxiety she never see before I mean
maybe she should get it on the smoking
doc take that and see or it could just
be something that he does away from her
if it helps him or Chur naughty little
secret yeah I mean who's he hurting dude
we had this kid named Caleb right and so
we got so high one time one of us he was
about to leave so somebody snuck out and
took his steering wheel off his car
right so then dude he goes out to his
car bro and he was looking for like
seven minutes and he comes back inside
and he's like ah you can tell he's kind
of nervous to tell us you know he's like
man I can't find my steering wheel right
and everybody's like oh you are [ __ ]
high bro you're an idiot you know you're
a psychopath you know cuz people just
throw that in you know and haha
and dude so we laughed for like ten
minutes all even he was laughing at the
fact I can't find my steering wheel
right now so in the meantime that guy
went back out and put his steering wheel
back into his car right so then we all
go out there as a group and the skin was
back on bro any [ __ ] loss oh hi bro
lost his mind who checked himself in a
mental health center and it's still
there still in the health center in 28
years 29 years so is that nature or
nurture you know it seemed to work out
for him well it's I don't know it's it's
kind of a bigger discussion but but what
I'm saying do it is look get high bro
you in the shed you getting high I think
you secretly want to get busted by your
lady I think it adds a little bit of
spark a little bit of spice to your life
dude I say get high get your lady in
there get blunted together and send us
another video and yeah and tell us
what's going on I want to send that
Blair Witch sex tape in the shed or just
sent a nice video introducing us to your
lady that worked
yeah like shoutout to this dude yeah
mark the spark baby blaze up dude I want
to see you get heated and play off
fluffy bunny to where you fill your
mouth with the marshmallows brah puffs
give to yourself all right boys rip my
trip up next first we got Alex from
Fresno this is Alex damn is that cheetah
print or tiger print big difference also
Christian flag on her phone their legend
country Jen she apparently is not a
stripper even though there is a stripper
pole in the background oh and she she a
freak confirmed and she starts teaching
first grade this year yeah yeah I never
had a teacher look like this I want to
go to preschool and this girl's butt
sorry that was too much I'm sorry that I
said that he seemed like a nice lady
what's her name again Alex Alex well I
still have to cover up them tattoos get
rid of the tiger print and take out the
nose person she's teaching anybody's kid
whatever she could teach the kid how to
have us keep a spare key on your nostril
right there we went on Adi mm-hmm heute
lady Alex
IX oh wow I would trick Brendon and what
else do we know about her shoes from
where Montana well Brendon spotted she
might be from Croatia with the Croatian
as in Fresno that's just a chequered
phone case that's not the Croatian flag
dude I'm not a stripper even though this
sounds differently regular oh that's her
fan we'll hang from the ceiling
correctly she has a balanced life bro
right here that's a ceiling fan this is
the pole right behind it but it looks
like the fan is collected if she doesn't
have the pole there so sometimes fans
don't want to be up in the air
also she might be a little stripper that
night though you know I'm saying maybe
she's that first grade superhero where
she's teaching the kids during the day
and helping the men at night nothing
wrong with that like Robin Hood dude
another bone for homework huh
that's what I'd be getting uh what else
does she say she likes to do what do
soccer no I didn't say she is a she's a
little bit of uh like a hot topic sexy
vibe going on done she with the tats the
print and she does Wow stick up the
brows I'm Becky oh yeah browsers open do
Google roam bro you feel me feel you
Doug I'm not mad at her good luck with
the kiddos man
hopefully my son has a teacher looks
like this yeah she's Drive seeing a
[ __ ] Warlocks man I had a teacher
Miss Deakin in seventh grade six for red
Wow still haunts me in this day
dude we had this lady miss miss Smith
and her husband was always dying every
day oh god it's annoying Smitty's dying
Smitty's dying and we'd all be sitting
there like we don't know how to spell
please help us please go over our rivers
with us Smitty's dying and for the
record I think miss Deacon was actually
Karl Mecklenburg in a wig oh yeah as a
shout-out to an old school football
player and what did that lady want from
us not to her we didn't even talk about
our clothes I like the skirt I guess and
yeah I like the tattoo coming out of the
white shirt it kind of makes it a little
bit more notice lips I like her brows I
like her nose piercing definitely have
to take that out from the kids
especially teacher conference tonight oh
dude I would balance my wiener on this
lady's back did she seem like a nice
lady and to say how old she is or no no
she didn't say oh good well shout out to
her see you later miss up next we got
Darwin Nash from Apache Junction Arizona
and Ching oh wow
it Dean ash huh ZZ Top laying low huh
it's like the Zac Brown Band
took some time away and lost some weight
yeah he's a that's a red beard like Zac
brown rice bro like this dude's been on
a diet um yeah this guy could definitely
be keeping secrets I think he looks like
a guy who actually keeps all the secrets
like he has a truck and has a lockbox in
the back and that's where all the secret
sauce it looked like his name is Ed and
owns a pawnshop of some sort like he has
a bunch of trinkets you know I'm saying
you might have a Rolex and a VCR in the
back and look at that little Dillo in
the back is that a Dillo on the ground
is that a puppy what was that a dill I
love a nice warm dill oh man oh that's a
puppy let's tough to tell that codon
could be a shaved armadillo yeah one
last time saw armadillo there's a
Mexican restaurant called armadillos in
Denver
yeah well out there anymore oh man well
I I Dino armadillos can jump about
probably eight or nine feet straight up
in the air no way if you look that up do
you mind for us please basically tanks
of the forest man yeah jumpin tanks they
can jump huh oh yeah dude now that I
think of it guys to pay looks like an
armadillo dude they're like the Vince
Carter of the animal kingdom Rob really
I didn't know that about armadillos can
they really jump are you thinking of
opossum armadillos can yeah awesome some
[ __ ] jump too let's see him jump bro
let's the armadillo an opossum in a dunk
contest oh yeah I love it
dude look here's what I'm saying is can
we see him jump or not armadillo does a
backflip these [ __ ] can leap boy
watch out here armadillos in New Orleans
do ya do it there's everywhere I want to
pet armadillo whoa damn that's that
Sonic the Hedgehog there but think about
how high that thing's jump is legs are
this big half long 80 inch of birth
boink see ya that dude I did not know
that gotta go fast they are too that's
pretty cool I thought they're slow
every time you play Brendan thinks he
hasn't seen it yet he's pretty cool
why is he slapped him so hard though it
was a strip club
oh man nobody's asked him you're not
making it rain
it's armadillo scared as [ __ ] in the
field there obviously this guy's doing a
lot of work with armadillos outdoors he
does a lot of you know and there's
another dog right there on the front
that has a sweater on it this kind of
likes putting sweaters on animals which
at a certain point weird vibe creeping
me out bro yeah yeah looks like summer
put a tank top on one of those em
efforts dude yeah no weird now you know
they say that deal it's a little weird
with the the sweaters on the dogs and
he's obviously holding a energy drink of
some sort yeah this guy's all hopped up
on bang energy and putting sweaters on
frickin on little poodles but you gotta
shut it down yeah
Zizi not let's move on thanks dad all
right boys we'll wrap it up with some
King at her sting it Oh get out of here
up first we got Keyshawn from Arizona
he's 19 this is Keyshawn do you love me
I was up there was uh Brandon Gang Gang
buzz buzz gang right so I saw this
youtuber pretty famous for did reviews
and he's a big fan of Chris D'Elia he's
a big baby but you know I like that
she's not honey more than that baby mush
but okay I wanted to know if he was okay
with someone and it's called dipped in
tobacco so I want to know your take on
it
dip in tobacco king of this thing in
Gang Gang buzz buzz Tripp listen the
only thing I'm dipping is honey you know
I'm saying I ain't trying to dip no
tobacco excuse me did you sign a
multi-million dollar contract with
angels unless you're a major league
baseball player you shouldn't be dipping
well but dude how do you get to the
major leagues if you ain't dippin get
questioned all the bigwigs dip dude
Manny Fernandez
yeah Julio rava derchi bruh all your
famous baseball players Pedro Martinez
only Ryan yeah Babe Ruth
yeah look here's the thing I used to
work on a farm I used to chew that plug
to back I'll put a hit of that in my lip
dude not gonna [ __ ] for about 40 minutes
and uh there's something about it going
straight into your system dude there's
just something about that straight
nicotine hit her into the lip yeah and
it's best a little different than
smoking but here's the thing if you're
hopped up on them all day man that's
just an addiction see there's gotta be
careful the healthier then smoking I
like it better man I like it I used to
do it
I like the plug the plug is a little bit
sweeter it's almost like it's a drug
it's just like a chunk of tobacco and
it's you know wet
oh yeah it's a juicy yeah it's kind of
wet and juicing you just bite a piece
off and then put it in your lip see I
don't like tobacco I mean I'm sorry yes
yeah it's got a lot like a dip because
it has like done house over here that
cuts into the lip that [ __ ] would burn
man yes some other sensual haver go live
you know I'm saying bro you could go
Coco yeah and Brazil they chew on this
thing it's like uh it's a plant
everybody's just walking around chewing
all that kratom and it's got something
wild in it yes that crate tone it's just
like a bootleg kind of dipper dip mm-hmm
everyone on my team did though in high
school yeah you dip ever I could see you
Devon what do you think about women that
dip okay I actually haven't seen anybody
dip before that's not really big where
I'm from that's not big where anyone's
from yeah does anyone still dip people
girls don't though do they
girls did everyone Memphis Tennessee
they dip in Brooklyn [ __ ]
immunes out in Memphis are in the dip
belt boy yeah and that's a lot of guys
with that you know just been into a jar
before they ask you a question that's
old-school man and so he's saying
they're just dipping in general yeah
again if you're a major league baseball
player making millions dip that [ __ ] if
you're not I don't think for your
financial status to determine whether or
not you feel comfortable chewing
doot-doot-doot and dipping chewing
tobacco damn you got that
okay browser all right what I'm saying
is some browsing no I'm talking about
yeah your name browser Shaw brother what
I'm saying is this brother if you want
to dip dip your [ __ ] face off bro
but be original about it put a little
plug up on any one of your eyeballs hit
that get that [ __ ] golden hitter
right up there by your [ __ ] sight
socket son you know I'm saying go deep
bro please you're here bro yeah do a
quarter gram and pack one of your
nostrils full bro you know I'm saying
change a game hide [ __ ] for cocoa
leaves in a couple of yuca left it's up
in your ass bro that's what I'm saying
do something unique you trying to get to
the moon put that dip in your anus
yeah put two ounces under your arm but
on its way to you get [ __ ] all heated
up carbon ice yeah the nassif hybrid do
something naughty cuz you can there's
other ways to get things into your body
man so don't just take the easy route by
taking it through the lip or taking it
through the lungs bro inject it between
your toes nah man but do something
unique you know put a little bit right
here and just hold your chin down for
long see if you get high till like
washers here with it see what happens
yeah wash your hair with that spit cup
spill off all that nicotine put it into
your hair man see what color you get use
it as a moisturizer
be brave man but dip your [ __ ] balls
off until they have to cut one of your
nuts out dude because you're from cancer
now you're gonna dip it up or you're not
gonna have teeth we could luck my man
yeah stop when you lose a tooth that's
good that's good advice I'm gonna sting
thanks man Oh Nick hang it we got case
aggressive from Wichita Kansas
oh I'm Barry Sanders country oh yeah
what's up guys is Casey from Wichita
Kansas is inhales going in her stinging
for you this is my wife in several of
her friends oh yeah cosplayers they make
costumes they go to comic-con
they run patreon it's basically make a
living doing that kind of stuff so King
under stinging cosplay guys I love your
show
Brennan you look like the oldest valet
at macaroni grill that pocketful other
people's change like something like pay
to have snaked out on my shower drain Oh
valet my crummy grilled good pretty good
cosplay they say you want to play
cosplay Bill Cosby has any people that
dress up like Joe Cocker
look here's the thing dr. Laura pending
cosplay man you know that's what we
called virgins when I was in high school
no say like in a good man
but a lot of them are freaks but if
they're older and they're in those
costumes then you're talking about
furries bro yeah you [ __ ] good for
your eyes you know what Furies are dude
hey go think of rocky the mascot for the
Nuggets but us rock down that movie mask
you mean sure that'd be a common bring
him up I'd be a costume of some sort
what cat was shaking her head about the
cosplayers yeah cat knows more about it
actually cat looks like a caused by
agree cosplayers are different he
brought up patreon so I'm thinking
they're cosplayers who basically dress
and like really skimpy clothes mmm it's
all the like sexy superhero clothes from
comic books yeah like - it's nothing but
like tits and ass Wow so it's kind of
its kind of uh
sign me up a cartoon meets sex kind of
yes exactly there's that anime I think
you can cosplay anime as well what's
there between cosplaying LARP LARP I
think you get dressed up and then you
pretend to fight people you gotta have a
sword too long and cause you're dressed
up with your swords and [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah oh come a counter cosplay I
thought it was Bill Cosby he will dress
him like Bill Cosby and Sheldon yeah
because I'm saying I'll dress up like
cockroach and show up and meet some
ladies you know yeah yeah no I got a
pillhead ladies showing up out there to
pose this question though just cause
congenic hi this is tough man I mean if
your girls out of shape shows up as
wonder worm won't wonder woman it bums
me out you know I'm saying
a few girl shows up as Wonder Woman then
yeah no wonder Worley if she shows she's
been Thor I'm gonna [ __ ] my pants and
I'm soon
that's just not for me i [ __ ] with it
I'm not if you want to do it do it
it's just nobody is saying it's not for
me man but I but I'm cool if you're into
it I get it dude right if you want to
dress up like ren and stimpy and [ __ ]
each other do it well they're not
necessarily [ __ ] this man is a wife
and they have our friends and they're
working yeah bro you think they dress up
as [ __ ] the Cookie Monster for the
hell of it [ __ ] no they swing those
outfits they go to these [ __ ] sheds
and do each other dude that's cosplay
bro I don't think that's it I'm telling
you not just going to dress up and
pretend they're Wolverine and Professor
X I don't think that's it at all I think
sometime they're showing a little bit of
artwork and different makeup stylings I
think there's a lot more to it than you
think there is I don't think either of
us know what the [ __ ] we're talking
about what I think you showed up in a
costume of Nolan Ryan today look at you
Rangers baby hey Hassan boy the house
all right I'm King it dress up and get
weird
I like cosplay dude I think it's a risky
move sometimes but I wouldn't feels in
an outfit every day but I'd like to see
more like wrestling WWF type of cosplay
- you know I'd like to see it go you
know and I'd like to see some Bill Cosby
I'd like to see people you know do
sweaters and get out there and you know
and uh but notnot do drugs or any sex
crimes but maybe just kind of you know
you see a woman sleeping or something
just put a sheet over just a blanket
make sure she's comfortable and give her
jello yeah
create the narrative just make sure
she's okay yeah I'm with you
all right boys last one Aaron Taylor
from Chicago what it is fellas it's
Aaron Taylor come at you from Chicago
Illinois
okay gang buzz buzz and bro got a king
of stinger for you it's starting to be
some around here people are stepping out
they got their hats the new shirts the
kicks etc but everything's store buy
it's branded they got a nike socks what
there's Nike shoes they're Nike shirts
or the guy champions sweater what have
you a lot of brands Mike interesting it
to you today is hand-painted apparel
much like this shirt right here this pie
see bros pie food truck that means that
the sting over here serving up them
creatine covered doughnuts got the King
driving the damn thing all in all it's a
nice little piece hand-painted by myself
okay
so I asked you store buy when branded
like Reebok champion boo wanna pray
Nestle in pain yeah a lot of bright side
note I'm working on something on the
back I'm gonna throw a menu on there and
then I'd love to send it to you guys do
I'm a big fan I've been rocking with you
since way back when you did the Yahoo
news updates
oh you calm Strunk Brendon you've been
to my bar a couple times down here I
love Holly Hall you've done a few shows
and then your homie the big gay al bryan
callen himself he just filmed this
special there's no both years to come
back in we can get a drink
shoot the [ __ ] Gang Gang buzz buzz
catches later cheers bro value holy [ __ ]
huh Talia Hall great spot in Chicago bro
big theater out the I never been there
that's a nice-looking shirt too and look
at that choice I swear struck hurt man I
love a square truck like that yeah me
too they're hard it's an apartment it's
whatever you want yeah it's like a food
truck it's the king the sting food truck
there yeah a bad investment this boy can
paint we got I like it I like the
original artwork
I'll get everything about this it's
always better to be original you don't
only go out everyone's wearing the same
goddamn thing you know I'm saying yeah I
remember I was young we had a store
called structure that they built and it
was like store
and it was the only store that was
really close enough and so we'd all go
to school like at the beginning of the
year and ever there would be like six
shirts and everybody had them on you
know everybody had on one of the six and
it was just weird it felt like you were
on these weird teams kind of all of a
sudden yeah I mean feel we're in the
same things the hands made tail in it so
you got to mix it up I like how this
guy's doing his thing hopefully sell
them [ __ ] yeah look I love some novelty
I love it yeah novelties big stuff for
me when I was young I remember you know
I used to cut my own hair dolls probably
about maybe 33 yes and or do different
stuff you know you got a wooden leg you
know a guy I remember in Tucson had
built a a straining to the side of it
and he would uh put it across one up on
his leg like that
cross it over and he have a little
ashtray built right into the side smart
you know so do something special had a
little birdseed and your beard you know
yeah magic but really you got a treat in
there yeah he's just trying to make sure
it's and that's why the birds are coming
by yeah but I'm saying originality I
would do this are you with me I'm with
you dude yeah charge this dude huh two
months now nobody's charged it who is we
at are we charging on we're someone
you're right is that it D that's it boys
Sudama
cigarette charges and guys legs and [ __ ]
I don't know man I said the guy had a
ashtray button to his leg it's called a
pirate bro yeah well he's also called
a pioneer okay talking about novelty I'm
special hang a birdhouse off the back
Ian neck you know do something unique
put a basketball hoop on yeah so I'm
saying like kids play [ __ ] you know
it's a traveling ball game they got a
fine they got to find you and they got a
dunk
so yeah that's always an away game you
understand it's always in a way so it's
a road game there you go bro don't touch
me do touch ba-ba-boom I'm in
Indianapolis this week Indy by Bob a bet
Indy and then in Nashville in Portland
get your tickets t5k Tom deal were you
gonna be brahbrah man gang July 13th
I'll be at
the Hollywood improv in Los Angeles and
Derrick might do it set maybe if he's in
town
don't even think about it I'm there okay
well so now we got Derrick in and if
you're in town when what day is that
it's a Saturday night but no pressure uh
you're welcome to it yeah I think if I'm
in town I'm there okay I'm on the road
but yeah that's it and to the tickets
are available Theo von comm / tour
that's it bro
that's it man don't touch me man but
keep touch like keep touching me Kat
thank you so much Derek love you guys
love you too man thank you for your for
being here with us and what else did we
cover everything that they remember to
do thanks for being humans everybody
yeah thanks for being human
[Music]